When it comes to running a successful
farm, few decisions are as important as
choosing the right tractor size. The
tractor is the heart of your operation,
powering everything from planting to
harvesting and even the daily chores
that keep your land in top shape. But
with so many options out there, how do
you know which one is right for you?
Today, we're digging deep into the topic
of tractor sizing, helping you
understand why it matters, what factors
to consider, and how to make the best
choice for your unique farm. Whether
you're a seasoned farmer or just
starting out, this guide will help you
make an informed decision that boosts
productivity and keeps costs in check.
Let's start by answering the big
question. Why does tractor size matter
so much? Imagine trying to tackle a
sprawling field with a tractor that's
just too small. You'd spend countless
hours going back and forth, burning
through fuel and wearing down your
equipment, not to mention yourself. On
the other hand, using a tractor that's
too large for your needs, can be just as
problematic. You'll spend more on fuel,
maintenance, and initial investment, all
for power you might never use. The key
is to find that ideal balance where your
tractor is powerful enough to handle
your workload efficiently, but not so
big that it becomes a burden. One of the
first things to consider is the size of
your farm. Acreage plays a huge role in
determining the right tractor for you.
For a small farm, say around 10 to 50
acres, a compact or utility tractor
might be just what you need. These
tractors are nimble, easy to maneuver,
and perfect for tasks like mowing,
hauling, and light fieldwork. But if
your operation covers hundreds of acres,
you'll likely need a larger, more
powerful machine that can tackle big
jobs quickly and efficiently. Next, take
a good look at your terrain. Is your
land flat and open, or does it feature
rolling hills and uneven ground? Steep
or rough terrain demands more horsepower
and better traction. A tractor that's
underpowered for your landscape will
struggle, leading to frustration and
potential safety hazards. On the other
hand, a tractor that's well matched to
your terrain will make your work
smoother and more enjoyable. Crop type
is another important factor. Different
crops require different equipment, and
that equipment often has specific power
requirements. For example, a vegetable
farmer working small plots might only
need a modestly powered tractor, while
someone growing row crops like corn or
soybeans will need a machine capable of
pulling larger implements and covering
more ground. Think about the implements
you'll use: plows, planters, harvesters,
and make sure your tractor can handle
them all. Now, let's talk about the
specific tasks you'll be tackling. Are
you primarily mowing and moving
materials, or will you be plowing,
planting, and harvesting on a large
scale? Each job places different demands
on your tractor. Light duty tasks like
mowing or hauling small loads can often
be handled by tractors in the 20 to 45
horsepower range. Medium duty work such
as tilling or bailing hay typically
requires 45 to 80 horsepower. And for
heavy duty jobs like deep plowing or
running large implements, you'll want a
tractor with 80 horsepower or more.
These are general guidelines, and your
specific needs may vary, but having a
clear idea of your workload will help
narrow down your options. To put these
ideas into perspective, let's look at a
few real world examples. Take Sarah, who
runs a 30 acre vegetable farm. She opted
for a 45 horsepower tractor, just the
right size for her smaller fields and
diverse set of tasks. Her tractor is
agile enough for precision work between
rows, but still strong enough for
tilling and harvesting when the time
comes. For Sarah, a larger tractor would
have been overkill, while a smaller one
wouldn't have kept up with her needs.
Now, consider Mike, who manages a 200
acre operation growing corn and
soybeans. He chose a 120 horsepower
tractor. A true workhorse capable of
handling heavy plowing and large
implements. With so much ground to
cover, Mike needs the extra power and
speed to get his work done efficiently,
especially during the busy planting and
harvest seasons. Finally, there's the
Johnson family who farm 500 acres of
mixed crops. They decided to invest in
two tractors, a 150 horsepower model for
major field work and a 60 horsepower
tractor for smaller jobs around the
farm. This setup gives them the
flexibility to tackle big and small
tasks simultaneously, boosting their
overall productivity and ensuring they
always have the right tool for the job.
So, how do you figure out the perfect
tractor size for your farm? Start by
making a list of all the tasks you need
to accomplish from the daily chores to
the seasonal fieldwork. Consider your
acreage, terrain, and the types of crops
you grow. Don't hesitate to reach out to
other farmers with similar operations.
They can offer valuable insights based
on their own experiences. And remember,
equipment dealers and agricultural
extension agents are there to help. They
can provide expert advice tailored to
your specific situation, ensuring you
make a well-informed decision. One more
thing to keep in mind, plan for the
future. If you're thinking about
expanding your farm or changing your
crop rotation, it might be wise to
invest in a tractor that's slightly
larger than your current needs. This
way, you won't outgrow your equipment as
your operation evolves, saving you time
and money down the road. In the end,
choosing the right tractor size is all
about finding the balance between power,
efficiency, and cost. The perfect
tractor is the one that meets your needs
without stretching your budget or
leaving you with more machine than
you'll ever use. By considering your
acreage, terrain, crop types, and the
specific tasks you need to accomplish,
you'll be well on your way to making a
smart investment that pays off for years
to come. Thank you for joining us on
this journey through the world of
tractor sizing. We hope you found these
insights helpful as you make your own
decision. Remember, the right equipment
can make all the difference in your
farming success. Stay tuned for more
practical tips and advice from Levuong
Agitech Agricultural Machinery. Until
next time, happy farming and may your
fields be ever fruitful.